[Musique]
sont-ils gay les français oui oui je
crois je ne crois pas ils sont plutôt
ironique et l'ironie suppose une
certaine assise vite et sont toujours en
train de rire oui à côté du futur bras
côté japonais oui ils sont assez
décontracté
[Musique]
c
ea table qu'il se tienne bien oui je
t'aime bien mais je remarque et qu'ils
trompent tout dans son café
c'était bouton est ce que la cuisine
française est bonne
excellente formidable oui elle est bonne
seulement il faut la similaires une des
meilleures ouvertement le techno ce
qu'il ya un plaque de préférer
éventuellement un le steak au poivre
la dose provençal steak frites et de
vert rouge les eaux bonnes femmes le
bourguignon
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
galanterie française
ça n'existe pas je crois qu'elle a un
peu disparu autour des plus de la
galanterie on se distrait se rassure pas
dans la vie je la trouve par moments un
peu servile et un peu intéressés on a
fait aux français la réputation d'être
des amants exceptionnel est-ce que vous
pensez que cela est vrai nos chais pas
comme norme chaque fois c'est pareil
n'importe quelle paix je crois pas
qu'ils sont particulièrement
exceptionnel sens des travaux d'un
membre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]